This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以难克难》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个节目探讨黑男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不安全的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少人身披铠甲。这向世界发出了一个信号：你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就必须这样做，听听如何以艰难的方式在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
以艰难的方式在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方学习。在2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。成群的互联网侦探花了一阵子才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例仅为2%。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. You guys know the deal. It is so great to have you here back another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. There is a very famous saying, at least I think it's famous, that if it was easy, everybody would be doing it. And when I was in university, I used to have that printed out on like a piece of paper. I think I even wrote it out. And I had it blue-tacked on my wall above my desk. And when I was studying for exams,
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们。相信我，宝贝》（Girlfriends. Trust me, babe），在iHeart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。大家懂的。很高兴大家能回来收看新的一集，当然，我们要剖析20多岁时的心理学。有一个非常著名的说法，至少我认为它很著名，那就是如果事情很简单，每个人都会去做了。当我在读大学时，我曾把这句话打印在一张纸上。我想我甚至还手写过。我用蓝丁胶把它粘在我书桌上方的墙上。当我复习准备考试时，
when I was working through assignments, it was kind of like my go-to phrase, for motivation to like embrace the hard stuff, to appreciate that hard things bring about the best rewards, that kind of gist. However, as I have gotten older and I was thinking about that quote the other day, and this is what has inspired that episode, as I've gotten older, I've sort of revised my thinking around this. You know, yes, definitely. Some of the best things in life do demand a lot of our effort, time, energy, attention. But does that necessarily mean that they need to be unenjoyable or difficult? Does it always have to be such like a mental slug? I think those words and like concepts tend to get all melted together when we talk about doing hard things. We imagine that
当我赶作业时，它就像是我的口头禅，给予我动力去拥抱困难的事物，去理解困难的事情能带来最好的回报，大致就是这个意思。然而，随着我年龄的增长，前几天我回想起那句话，这也正是启发这期节目的原因，随着年龄的增长，我对这句话的看法有所修正。你知道，是的，绝对如此。生活中的一些美好事物确实需要我们付出大量的努力、时间、精力、关注。但这是否一定意味着它们必须令人不快或充满困难呢？难道它总是必须像是一场精神上的拉锯战吗？我认为当我们谈论做难事时，这些词汇和概念往往会融为一体。我们想象着
they have to be almost painful. I also think, you know, with that quote, there is also this underlying secondary sense that maybe you and I, we don't deserve success if we don't almost suffer for it, if we don't strive for it, if it, you know, came to us easily. Today, I want to talk about that. I want to talk about this idea of how we can train our brain to do hard things by offering you a different approach, a different formula or understanding, one in which hard things become easier using some of these principles of psychology that mean that we find difficult tasks less mentally taxing, we find it less difficult to start, we appreciate the rewards more, you know, all motivation, our desire to do anything big or small, even the most mundane of
它们几乎必定是痛苦的。我还认为，你知道，随着那句名言，还有一个潜在的次要感觉，那就是也许你和我，如果我们不为之近乎痛苦地挣扎，如果我们不为之奋斗，如果成功轻易降临，我们就不配拥有成功。今天，我想谈谈这个。我想谈谈这样一个想法：我们可以通过提供一种不同的方法、不同的公式或理解，来训练我们的大脑去做困难的事情，在这种方法中，借助某些心理学原理，困难的事情会变得更容易，这意味着我们发现困难任务在精神上的消耗会减少，开始做事的难度也会降低，我们会更懂得欣赏回报，你知道，所有的动机，我们想要做任何大或小事情的渴望，甚至是再平凡不过的任务。
tasks. It all starts in the brain and it all starts with how we perceive how difficult the thing in front of us is and how we perceive the outcome and the rewards of our hard effort. That is actually something that we can influence, we can influence how our brain kind of perceives all of these components and mean that the hard, difficult things that all of us have to do in our 20s, like the things that are just so frustrating and annoying that we often put off become less of a chore. I will also say our brain does like a challenge, even when it's a bit physically, mentally painful. That's something that I think sometimes we forget when we just keep taking the easy route, which I'm definitely guilty of. The New York Marathon, as I'm
这一切都始于大脑，始于我们如何看待眼前事情的难度，以及我们如何看待努力付出的结果和回报。这实际上是我们可以影响的事情，我们可以影响大脑如何看待所有这些成分，这意味着我们20多岁时都必须面对的那些艰巨、困难的事情——比如那些让我们极其沮丧和烦恼、因而常常被我们拖延的事情——将不再那么像是一种杂务。我也要说，大脑确实喜欢挑战，哪怕它在身体和精神上有那么一点痛苦。这是有时当我们不断选择捷径时往往会忘记的事情，而我对此绝对也难辞其咎。正如我正在录音时那样，纽约马拉松赛
recording this, was I think a couple of weeks ago. I love the New York Marathon and every time I watch it, I think, why does anyone want to do that? And the answer is that the feeling is that the feeling of doing hard things that exert us is something that we actually value as humans. That is something that actually we do need more of in our lives. It all comes down to this thing known as the effort paradox. The more effort we put into something, the more we value it. That's why, you know, you value the crappy mug that you made at a pottery class over the perfect mug that you got at IKEA.
我想就在几周前。我喜欢纽约马拉松，每次观看时，我都想，为什么会有人想做那种事？答案是，完成消耗体力的艰难之事的这种感觉，是我们作为人类真正珍视的东西。这确实是我们生活中需要更多的东西。这一切都归结于一个被称为“努力悖论”的概念。我们在一件事情上投入的努力越多，我们就越珍视它。这就是为什么，你知道，你比从宜家买来的完美马克杯更珍视你在陶艺课上自己做的那个粗糙的马克杯。
The end of a hard project is valued more than. the outcome of an easy one and it actually does make our life feel more fulfilling, we feel proud of ourselves and we just reap the rewards. So today, let us break down exactly how we can use the principles of behavioral psychology mainly, but also neuroscience to do the hard things, to start the hard routines, especially in our 20s when we can reap a lot of lifelong rewards from getting into the habit from biting the bullet. So without further reduced, Let's break down the psychology of how you and I can train our brains to do just that. The journey to completing or starting anything hard all actually has the exact same start line.
一个艰难项目结束时的成果比一个简单项目的成果更受珍视，它确实能让我们的生活感觉更充实，我们会为自己感到骄傲，并且我们只是收获了回报。所以今天，让我们详细剖析我们如何能够利用行为心理学的原理（主要是行为心理学，但也包括神经科学）来做困难的事情，来开启困难的日常，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，当我们通过养成习惯、咬紧牙关，可以收获许多受用终身的报酬时。因此，废话不多说，让我们来剖析一下你和我如何训练大脑做到这一点的心理学。完成或开始任何艰难事情的旅程，其实都有着完全相同的起跑线。
And the start line is going from doing nothing to doing something. And I think a lot of us know that that transition, that jump from doing nothing to something is the hardest. and it stops a lot of us from ever really beginning, even if we really, really want to see where something's going to take us. That is why my first biggest tip for how we can train our brain to do hard things is the five-minute rule. You know, after you begin, the first five minutes of anything is going to be the hardest because you have to dig deep and find the motivation to just begin and to deal with that tension from going from doing nothing to doing something.
而起跑线就是从什么都不做转变为做点什么。我想我们很多人都知道，这种转变，从无所事事到付诸行动的跨越是最艰难的，它阻止了我们中的许多人真正开始，即使我们真的很想看看某件事会把我们带向何方。这就是为什么我关于如何训练大脑做难事的第一个最大建议是：五分钟规则。你知道，在你开始之后，任何事情的前五分钟都将是最艰难的，因为你必须深入挖掘并找到动力去刚刚开始，去应对从无所事事过渡到做点什么所带来的那种紧张感。
And a big part of why that is so daunting is that it feels like when we begin a new task or we begin a new routine or we're like, okay, I'm committed to going to the gym every single morning or I'm committed to in this moment right now finishing my assignment and I need to work on it in this moment right now absolutely have to do it even though I don't want to do it. it often is like, okay, by telling myself that I need to do that, I now am committing to a lot more than just a couple of minutes. I'm committed to a whole process, a whole period of time where I have to be focused on this task. And it's that huge mountain and the idea of climbing that mountain, knowing it's going to take a while, that means that we put things off because of the time burden.
之所以让人感到如此畏惧，很大一部分原因在于，当我们开始一项新任务或新日常时，或者当我们觉得“好吧，我决心每天早上都去健身房”或者“我决心此刻立刻完成我的作业，我必须现在就着手去做，绝对必须去做，尽管我一点都不想做”，感觉往往会变成：“好吧，通过告诉自己我必须这样做，我现在承诺的不仅仅是几分钟。我承诺的是整个过程，是一整段我必须专注于这项任务的时间。”正是那座巨大的山峰以及攀登这座山峰的想法——明知它需要一段时间——意味着我们会因为时间负担而拖延事情。
instead we want to overcome our brain's natural tendency to want to avoid discomfort that comes with the beginning of the task by saying I will just do this for five minutes it's not actually a trick you are only going to do the thing for five minutes unless after you have you know lasted that period of time you feel better about the thing you feel better about doing it if you're five minutes into your run and you're like, okay, I've done five minutes. I can stop. I'm allowed to stop because I've done better than doing nothing. But, you know, maybe I'll just do another minute. Maybe I'll do another minute after that. You see that you have overcome the first mental barrier. You've overcome that first point of tension. This is just such a simple, accessible, cognitive
相反，我们要克服大脑想要逃避任务开始时带来的不适感的自然倾向，方法是告诉自己：我只做五分钟。这其实不是什么诡计，你真的就只做五分钟，除非在度过了那段时间之后，你对这件事感觉更好，觉得做这件事感觉不错。如果你跑步进行了五分钟，然后想：“好吧，我已经做了五分钟。我可以停下来。我被允许停下来，因为这总比什么都不做要好。”但是，你知道，也许我再多跑一分钟。也许在那之后我再多跑一分钟。你会发现你已经克服了第一个心理障碍。你已经克服了最初的紧张点。这简直是一个极其简单、易行且认知
behavioral strategy. And the reason that it works so much is also because it essentially tricks us into not being able to procrastinate. Now, one of the foundations of procrastination, a lot of people think, assume that it's laziness. It's actually not, it's perfectionism. If you are an overachiever, you are a big thinker, you are a perfectionist. The beginning of a task is always going to be the hardest because it's in that moment that you realize how much opportunity in space, there is to fail, how much space there is to do it wrong, how much space there is to be criticized, to not live up to your expectations, that is scary. And that is what's causing you to procrastinate and causing you to put off this reality that you're so fearful of. But the five-minute
行为的策略。而它之所以如此有效，很大程度上也是因为它实质上是在欺骗我们，让我们无法拖延。现在，拖延症的基础之一，很多人认为、假设那是懒惰。其实不然，它是完美主义。如果你是一个追求卓越的人、一个深度思考者、一个完美主义者。任务的开始总是最艰难的，因为正是在那一刻，你意识到有多少机会和空间可能会失败，有多少空间可能会出错，有多少空间可能会受到批评，无法达到你的期望，这太可怕了。而这正是导致你拖延并促使你逃避这个让你如此恐惧的现实的原因。但是五分钟的
rule undercuts that because it looks at this perfection as part of our brain and says, actually, like, you can clock off for this because anything that I do in five minutes is not going to be perfect. So great, I know that. That's amazing. I can just actually ignore my perfectionism for this moment and just give it a go. It doesn't have to be perfect. It definitely doesn't have to be done. And by the time you have gotten that momentum, suddenly your perfectionism is kind of like
规则削弱了这一点，因为它审视了我们大脑中这个追求完美的成份并说道：“事实上，你可以为此打卡下班，因为我在五分钟内做的任何事情都不会是完美的。所以太好了，我知道这一点。这太棒了。此刻我其实可以忽略我的完美主义，直接去尝试一下。它不需要完美。绝对不需要完成。”而当你积聚了这种动量时，突然之间，你的完美主义就像是在
trying to play catch up. It's like, hey, wait, you tricked me. I thought that we were like not actually going to do this today. I thought that we were going to like give it a break. Like I thought that, you know, I'd stopped you. It's like, actually. know when you start giving it a go when you get on like the fast train you start seeing that it's easier you start seeing that actually you're doing better than you expected perhaps and you also start
试图迎头赶上。它仿佛在说：“嘿，等等，你骗了我。我以为我们今天其实不打算做这个。我以为我们要歇一歇。我以为，你知道，我已经阻止你了。”而事实是：其实，当你开始尝试，当你踏上快车道，你开始发现事情变得更容易，你开始发现实际上你做得比预期更好，或许你也开始
realizing that progress is just it's just important you've already made a dent and now you have something to work with so the five minute rule anything that you know is going to be hard just say you have to do it for five minutes and and like I said before you do only have to do it for five minutes. So if you're at the end of that period of time and you're like, okay, I want to stop, that's fine. You're allowed to stop, but at least you did it. My second tip, and this one is possibly one of my favorite strategies. I use this all the time. When I know I have to do something that is daunting, that is challenging, that I don't want to do, I picture the best person I know at that thing. I picture them doing it. I think about them.
意识到进步本身就是重要的，你已经取得了突破，现在你有了可以着手处理的东西。所以五分钟规则——任何你知道会有困难的事情——只需说你必须做五分钟。而且就像我之前说的，你确实只需要做五分钟。所以如果你在那段时期结束时觉得“好吧，我想停下来”，那也没关系。你被允许停下来，但至少你做到了。我的第二个建议，这个可能是我最喜欢的策略之一。我经常使用这个。当我明知自己必须做某件令人畏惧的、具有挑战性的、我不想做的事情时，我在脑海中想象我认识的在这方面最优秀的人。我想象他们正在这样做。我思考他们。
I think about how they hold themselves. I think about how they would go about it. It's a really powerful form of mental imagery. And when we concoct these mental images in our brain, it serves as a form of motivation. So, for example, anytime I need to do public speaking, I always think about my mom because my mom is absolutely excellent at it. She's amazing. And I think about like almost stepping into her shoes, stepping into her outfit, believing that I am her and it's that admiration but also the fact that she has set an example that I can almost copy that makes me feel a lot more capable it's almost like I actually don't you know I don't have
我想象他们是如何保持自律的。我想象他们会如何着手去做。这是一种非常强大的心理意象形式。当我们在脑海中构思这些心理意象时，它就成了一种动力的来源。例如，每当我需要进行公众演讲时，我总是会想到我的妈妈，因为我妈妈在这方面绝对极其优秀。她太棒了。我就会想象自己几乎是踏入了她的鞋子，穿上了她的衣服，相信我就是她，正是这种钦佩，再加上她树立了一个我可以几乎去复制的榜样，让我觉得自己有能力得多。这几乎就像我其实不用，你知道，
to do all of this myself someone else that I know who I respect who is great at this has already done it for me all I need to do is emulate them all I need to do is copy them I also I will say do this at the gym all the time, like as a way to stick to the hard parts of like my gym workouts and my gym routine. But instead of thinking about the best person I know at the gym, which to be honest would probably also be my mom, which is crazy because she's just a legend. But instead of thinking about someone I really admire and copying them and thinking about what they would do, I actually also visualize this person in my mind called gym jimmer or a little. I actually, also visualize this person in my mind called Jim Gemma or Elite Gemma.
这一切都不需要我自己来做——我认识的另一个我尊重并且在这方面很优秀的人已经为我做过了，我需要做的就是效仿他们，我需要做的就是复制他们。我还要说，我在健身房也经常这样做，以此来坚持健身锻炼和健身日常中艰难的部分。但不是去想我认识的健身最好的人（说实话那可能还是我妈妈，这太疯狂了，因为她简直是个传奇），而是不去想我真正钦佩的人并复制他们、思考他们会怎么做，我其实也会在脑海中可视化这样一个人，叫做“健身杰玛”（Gym Gemma）或者叫“精英杰玛”。实际上，我也会在脑海中可视化这样一个人，叫做“健身杰玛”或“精英杰玛”。
And Elite Gemma is like this really focused, fit version of myself that I've created. And I think about what she would do. I think about how confident she would be. I think about what moves she would do, what her routine would look like, how she would go about it? Would she care about those other people looking at her? No, she wouldn't. And Elite Gemma is who I step into in those moments where I'm like,
而精英杰玛就像是我创造出的一个非常专注、身材健美的自我版本。我会去想她会做什么。我会去想她会有多自信。我会去想她会做什么动作，她的日常会是什么样，她会如何着手去做？她会在乎其他那些看着她的人吗？不，她才不在乎。而精英杰玛就是我在那些时刻所代入的角色——当我感觉
I don't really want to do this. but she would, and I have to listen to what she would do here, so I need to go. So there is a great study from 2019 on this exact topic, and it's titled Mental Imetry as a motivational amplifier to promote activities. And I love this, amplifier. It doesn't give you all the motivation to begin with, but it takes that tiny bit of sensation in you that wants to do something and says, you are capable, you are able to do this. So this study, it showed that when participants visualised themselves doing hard activities or hard things
“我其实不太想做这个”，但她会去做，而我必须听从她在这里会做的事情，所以我得去。因此，2019年有一项关于这个确切主题的出色研究，其标题为《作为激励放大器的心理意象以促进活动》。我喜欢这个词，“放大器”。它并不会一开始就给你提供所有的动力，而是汲取你体内那微小的想要做事的冲动，然后对你说：你有能力，你能够做到这一点。因此，这项研究表明，当参与者可视化自己进行艰难的活动或困难的事情
and then being successful or finishing the task, this was associated with higher activity completion compared to those who were just given a task and told to go about it. The other reason and I guess the other way in which I think mental imagery is really important here is that it is a great source of bravery and it is a great way to fake it till you make it. And I'm going to give another example here of how I used a very similar visualization technique when I was trying to get over my fear of flying. I would imagine that I was someone famous and I would really picture being this famous person who caught all these planes all the time. This was like a part of my fast, luxurious life and just like rehearsing that and thinking about that over and over again,
然后取得成功或完成任务时，这与那些仅仅被分配了任务并被告知去做的人相比，与更高的任务完成度相关联。我认为心理意象在这里很重要的另一个原因、或者说另一种方式是，它是勇敢的绝佳来源，也是“假装直到你成功”（fake it till you make it）的绝妙方法。这里我将给出另一个例子，说明当我试图克服恐飞症时，是如何运用非常相似的可视化技术的。我会想象自己是一个名人，我会真切地想象自己就是那个经常赶飞机的名人。这就像是我快节奏、奢华生活的一部分，只需不断地排练和思考，
creating that mental loop and repetition. I am this person. I'm emulating this person. It made me feel insanely powerful, insanely capable. And it was a complete game changer. So that is a way that you can use your ability, your very amazing special human ability to create mental images in your mind, you can use that to trick yourself into feeling more capable. You've got to remember, your mind is the source of all your beliefs about how able you are and how brave you are and how courageous you are. So if you feed it all of this like artificial confidence that is based on how someone else does things or how a future or an amazing version of yourself does things, it's going to eat that up and it's not going to know the difference between that.
在脑海中创造出那种精神循环和重复。我是这个人。我在效仿这个人。这让我感到拥有了不可思议的力量、不可思议的能力。这是一个彻底的改变者。所以，这就是你可以利用自己的能力——你那极其美妙的特殊人类能力，在脑海中创造心理意象——来欺骗自己，让自己感觉更有能力的一种方式。你必须记住，你的心态是你关于自己有多少能力、有多勇敢、有多无畏的所有信念的源泉。因此，如果你给它灌输所有这些基于别人如何做事、或者未来或极好版本的自己如何做事的“人工自信”，它就会全盘接受，并且不会察觉到其中的区别
and a negative or self-doubting thought. So it's an incredible technique. Let's move on from this and talk about mood. Talk about emotions. So if you have got something on your to-do list that you have been avoiding for a while because it is hard, because it is boring, because you just simply don't want to do it, you have got to choose the right mood to start tackling that. You've got to choose the right mood to implement your five minutes. A 2016 study found that when people are upset, they are less likely to try and do hard things. Very common sense, I understand. Sometimes we do just need like a good old-fashioned psychological study to prove what we already know. And the explanation behind why this is the case is also quite simple. When you're in a bad mood, all of your mental resources
与负面或自我怀疑的想法有何不同。所以这是一个不可思议的技巧。让我们从这里继续，谈谈情绪。谈谈情感。所以，如果你的待办任务清单上有什么事情，因为困难、因为无聊、或者因为你单纯不想做，而已经被你逃避了一段时间，你必须选择合适的心态去开始应对它。你必须选择正确的心态来执行你的“五分钟”。2016年的一项研究发现，当人们心烦意乱时，他们尝试做难事的可能性就会降低。这绝对是常识，我理解。有时我们确实需要一个老派的心理学研究来证明我们已经知道的事情。而这背后的解释其实也很简单。当你心情不好时，你所有的心理资源
are at a lower point. They're all kind of plummeting, right? So you're not going to feel as motivated. You're not going to feel like you have any energy. You're also, well, your mind is going to look at this hard task and it's going to make it feel a lot bigger and a lot more difficult, a lot more challenging as a way to convince you to rest,
都处于较低点。它们都在某种程度上暴跌，对吧？所以你不会觉得有动力。你不会觉得自己有任何精力。而且，你的大脑在看到这个困难任务时，会让它感觉大得多、困难得多、更具挑战性，以此来作为一种说服你休息的方式，
convince you to get yourself back to a positive mental state by not putting any more pressure on yourself as it is. During those times, that is not the time when you want to start doing the hard thing. That is not the time when you want to start doing your chores. That is not the time when you want to, you know, suddenly handle your taxes after you've had like a really long day at work. You've missed your train. You're having a fight with your friend.
说服你让自己回到积极的心理状态，而不再给自己施加更多本已沉重的压力。在那些时候，那可不是你想要开始做难事的时候。那不是你想开始做家务的时候。那不是你想在经历了漫长的工作日、错过了火车、和朋友吵了一架之后，突然去处理报税的时候。
There's not enough food in the fridge. No. Because also another element of that is that you will end up resenting the activity even more when you have to do it when you're in a bad mood. And if you're trying to train yourself into a habit, but every time you go about doing the habit or practicing the behavior that is associated with it, every time you do that, if you're in a terrible mood, guess what's going to become associated? The terrible mood and the behavior. And it's going to become almost like this pattern or this link or this relationship in your brain that when you think about the
冰箱里食物都不够了。绝不。因为其中的另一个元素是，当你必须在心情不好的时候去做这件事时，你最终会对这项活动产生更多的怨恨。如果你试图让自己养成一个习惯，但每次你去执行这个习惯或练习与之相关的行为时，每次你这样做，如果你心情极糟，你猜什么会和它联系在一起？糟糕的心情和这种行为。它几乎会变成你大脑中的一种模式、一种联系或一种关系，每当你想到
when you think about the whatever it is thing that you need to do, your brain's going to be like, huh, every time we do that, we're in a bad mood. And it doesn't see like the correlation or the causation points or it doesn't see like the chicken or the egg problem, which one came first. So it's really important to build positive associations when we are doing hard things. I'm going to use the gym example again and just think that it's like the easiest because it's like a behavior where you go to the same place and it's like something that a lot of us are probably going to be focused on in the new years.
每当你想到那个你需要做的事情时，你的大脑就会觉得：“哈，每次我们做那个时，我们都心情不好。”它看不到相关性或因果关系的要点，也看不到先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，究竟哪个在先。所以在我们做难事时，建立积极的联想真的很重要。我将再次使用健身的例子，并认为这是最简单的，因为这是一种你去同一个地方的行为，而且这也是我们许多人在新年里可能会关注的事情。
If you are in a really bad mood, and I'm going to tell you something that is probably counterintuitive, if you are in a really bad mood and one of your long-time goals is to go to the gym more often, actually don't go to the gym during those times. Some people would argue that the endorphins are going to make you feel better, yada, yada, yada, in some ways I think that is the case. But if you're going to go to the gym and just do a really crappy workout and you're not going feel like you pushed yourself, you're not even going to get to that place of an endorphine high. Actually, what you're doing before you even get there is associating the bad mood with the behavior.
如果你心情真的很糟，我要告诉你一件可能有些反直觉的事：如果你心情真的很糟，而你长期以来的目标之一就是更频繁地去健身房，那么实际上在那些时候就不要去健身房。有些人会辩称内啡肽会让你感觉更好，云云，在某些方面我认为确实如此。但如果你去健身房却只是进行了一次糟糕至极的锻炼，而且感觉不到自己付出了努力，你甚至都无法到达内啡肽分泌的高潮。实际上，在你还没到那儿之前，你正在做的是把糟糕的心情与这种行为联系起来。
So when you are in the best mood, you've had a great day, you're feeling motivated. That's when you've got to almost like slide in the hard tasks. It's like when parents like sneak vegetables into like meatballs or into like cookies. That's what you're doing here. someone said to me when I like first talk to them about this like that's such a waste of a good mood like why would I do that but actually completing a hard task when you are already in a good mood has been shown to elevate that mood even further and there is a continuation so you feel really good in the moment but then you also continue to feel good in the minutes hours even sometimes days afterwards maybe in part because of
所以，当你处于最好的心情、度过了美好的一天、感到充满动力时。那才是你几乎必须像“滑入”困难任务的时候。就像父母把蔬菜偷偷塞进肉丸或饼干里一样。这就是你在这里所做的。有人曾对我说，当我第一次和他们谈论这个时：“这太浪费好心情了——我为什么要那么做？”但事实证明，当你已经心情很好时去完成一项困难的任务，实际上会把这种心情提升到更高的水平，并且会产生一种延续效应：你在当下感觉非常好，但在之后的几分钟、几小时、甚至有时几天里，你也会继续感觉良好，部分原因可能是因为
relief like oh gosh finally i did it that's done but also in part because of a sense of pride you know how often do we actually challenge ourselves and seriously when was the last time you put a lot of effort into something and it took a lot of commitment from you and there were times when you datted yourself and you didn't really want to do it when was the last time you did that because as an adult i do think that that's not as common anymore it might be in like a workplace environment. But when it comes to your personal life, we very often, we don't tend to often, you know, just jumping all over my words there, we don't often tend to changing it up again. We don't often tend to actually push ourselves. So I think that it's really important to actually
如释重负——“哦天哪，总算做完了，事情解决了”，但部分原因也是因为一种自豪感。你知道我们多久才会真正挑战自己一次吗？说真的，你上一次把大量精力投入到某件事中是什么时候？那需要你极大的投入，期间你曾怀疑过自己，而且你其实并不太想做——你上一次这样做是什么时候？因为作为一个成年人，我认为这已经不那么常见了。在职场环境中可能会有。但说到你的个人生活，我们非常经常地——我的话又说得磕磕绊绊了——我们往往不经常，你知道，又在换话题了。我们往往不经常真正去推动自己。所以我认为，真正给自己一个机会去做这件事、给自己一剂自信心的强心剂、为已经很好的心情再添一把火，这真的很重要。
give yourself the opportunity to do that, to give yourself the confidence booster, to give yourself that further amplifier to your mood already. We're going to to take a short little break because obviously I need to have a drink of water since I am just tumbling all over my words here. But when we return, we're going to talk about how you can fall in love with the process and the different kinds of extrinsic, intrinsic and integrated motivation that you can use to do hard things. Stay with us. We'll be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
我们要稍作休息，因为显然我需要喝口水，我刚才说话都语无伦次了。但当我们回来时，我们将讨论如何爱上这个过程，以及你可以利用的外在动机、内在动机和整合动机的不同类型来完成难事。请继续收听。我们马上回来。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例仅为2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships,
我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些困难，
and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier（健康）的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍了一下）小姬姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush Got to do a little Kim. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析其背后的来龙去脉，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代快克（可卡因）的节目。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都可以谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在也把“艾滋病”摆上台面了。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《以难克难》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我十多年来
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
在心理健康领域的亲身经验，
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某事的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。你之所以是个好人，是因为你心怀恐惧吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是去做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《以难克难》中，就治愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用。搜索《以难克难》并立即收听。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。成群的互联网侦探花了一阵子才破了这个案子。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There is a psychological theory that when we don't just fall in love with the result, but we fall in love with the process, we actually perform better and we get further. And this theory is known as learned industriousness. Here's the thing about doing everything for like the big golden finish line, right?
我想让人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。有一个心理学理论：当我们不仅爱上结果，而且爱上过程时，我们的表现实际上会更好，走得也会更远。这个理论被称为“习得勤奋”（learned industriousness）。事情是这样的，如果做每件事都只是为了那个巨大的金色终点线，对吧？
Anything hard you are just thinking about what it's going to be like when it's done, when it's over, when you have the reward. it actually takes a while to get there and along that path along that route there's probably not going to be a lot of you know encouragement to spur you on people might not believe in you the thing that you're doing might just be very mundane no one's going to be celebrating you shouting like yay you've got this maybe there's not like any reward that you could even provide yourself during that time so if you are doing it all for the final outcome you are going to, unfortunately, probably lose steam. So what this theory says is that individuals who are reinforced for exerting high effort on a task, they don't just fall in love with the outcome.
无论做什么难事，你都只想著当它完成时会是什么样、当它结束时会是什么样、当你拿到奖励时会是什么样。实际上达到那个目标需要一段时间，而在通往那里的道路上、在那条路线上，可能不会有很多，你知道的，能够鼓舞你前行的鼓励，人们可能不相信你，你正在做的事情可能非常平凡，没有人会为你庆祝并大喊“耶，你真棒”，也许在那段时间里甚至没有任何你可以提供给自己的奖励。所以，如果你做这一切仅仅是为了最终的结果，不幸的是，你很可能会失去动力。因此，该理论表明，那些因为在任务中付出高努力而得到强化的个人，他们并不只是爱上结果。
They actually, in some ways, get hooked or get addicted purely to the sensation of performing highly, purely to the sensation of exerting themselves. So we flip the whole narrative away from the physical tantal. outcome and towards a love for like the everyday hard actions that get us there. So how do we do that? Well, we'll, well, a few ways. Firstly, is by really romanticizing the process, really falling in love and getting quite sentimental about what it feels like to perform a task day and day out, what it feels like to be working towards your goals. Like what a privilege that is, how romantic it is. What's that story going to look like? What's that going to feel like?
在某些方面，他们实际上会迷上或沉迷于纯粹的高绩效带来的感觉，纯粹沉迷于付出努力的感觉。所以我们彻底扭转了这种叙事，不再关注遥不可及的结果，而是转向热爱那些促使我们达到目标的日常艰苦行动。那么我们该怎么做呢？好吧，嗯，有几种方法。首先，真正将这个过程浪漫化，真正爱上并对日复一日执行任务的感觉产生相当多的感伤，对为了目标而努力的感觉产生感伤。这是一种多么特权的事情，多么浪漫啊。那段故事会是什么样的？那种感觉会是怎样的？
I did this a lot when I was writing my book and I was staying up late and I felt very stressed. But instead of being like, oh my God, this just sucks it, I'm just so tired. I would like imagine that I was Ernest Hemingway or like a famous author working into the night in Paris on my book with a glass of wine. And I was like this tortured author, poet type. And I created this whole image that made me really feel like it was like fun. It was fun to not so much suffer, but it was fun to strive. It was fun to work hard. There was like this glamour associated with it. There was this romanticism that made it special and fun and like I have actually like very fond memories of those times. You know, even when it was
当我写书时我经常这样做，我熬夜到很晚，感到压力非常大。但与其抱怨“哦天哪，这太糟糕了，我太累了”，我会在脑海中想象自己是欧内斯特·海明威（Ernest Hemingway）或者某个著名的作家，深夜在巴黎的灯光下手里拿着一杯酒写书。我感觉自己像是一个受折磨的作家、诗人类型。我创造了整个意象，让我真的觉得这很有趣。与其说是受苦，不如说奋斗是很有趣的。努力工作是很有趣的。其中有一种与之相关的魅力。有一种浪漫主义让它变得特别和有趣，并且——我实际上对那些时光有着非常美好的回忆。你知道，即使当它
really, really like it felt nice knowing that I could push myself. Another way of doing this is by really noticing the signs of progress and letting them serve as the reward to kind of further fuel your fire. So the feeling of sore muscles, the feeling of being really mentally tired at the end of the day, but like super fulfilled and super satisfied and like falling asleep and just feeling really great about yourself. The feeling of seeing, I don't know, your art get better, seeing your writing get better, seeing your grades get better. That is a way of bringing about learned industriousness. It's why I really, one of the things I really recommend
真的——感觉只要知道自己能够挑战极限，就觉得很美好。做到这一点的另一种方法是，真正注意到进步的迹象，并让它们成为奖励，以进一步点燃你的热情。因此，肌肉酸痛的感觉，一天结束时精神极度疲劳但超级充实、超级满意、入睡时对自我感觉极佳的感觉。看到，我不知道，你的艺术变得更好，看到你的写作变得更好，看到你的成绩变得更好。这就是实现习得勤奋的一种方式。这就是为什么我真的，我强烈推荐的一件事，
and that I love when people do this is when they set up Instagram pages for like their projects, like their marathons or an art project or they're like when they're learning your language or when they're renovating their house, like setting up a progress page or a project page. You can really see how things get better and improve and get bigger and larger
而且当我看到人们这样做时我超级喜欢，那就是他们为自己的项目建立Instagram页面，比如他们的马拉松或艺术项目，或者当他们正在学习一门语言或正在装修房子时，建立一个进度页面或项目页面。你真的可以看到事情是如何变得更好、如何改进、如何变得越来越宏大，
and dreams come true. My God, I sound so cliche. But you really can see that day in and day out. It gets better every single day. Finally, the best way to really promote learned industriousness and the way that really aligns best with the theory is to just simply reinforce your effort through physical reward. So what this really relies on is something known as the hedonic principle.
梦想成真。天哪，我听起来太老套了。但你确实可以日复一日地看到这一点。它每天都在变得更好。最后，真正促进习得勤奋的最佳方法、也是与该理论最契合的方法，就是通过物质奖励来简单地强化你的努力。所以这真正依赖的是一个被称为“享乐原则”的概念。
As humans, as creatures, as people with brains, We are wired towards things that make us feel good and we are wired to avoid things that make us feel uncomfortable. Super simple principle, right? But an easy way to make an uncomfortable thing feel good is by maximizing the pleasure and the reward we get from it. So the more candy, I don't know, like the more candy you offer to a child, the more excited they're going to be to go to the dentist even if they hate the dentist.
作为人类，作为生物，作为拥有大脑的人，我们生来就倾向于让我们感觉良好的事物，而生来就会避开让我们感到不舒服的事物。超级简单的原则，对吧？但让一件不舒服的事情感觉良好的一个简单方法，就是最大化我们从中获得的快乐和奖励。所以，给小孩子提供越多的糖果，我不知道，比如提供越多的糖果，他们就会越兴奋地去看牙医，即使他们讨厌牙医。
the more treats you give a puppy, like the more obedient they become, allegedly, that's always backfired and made my puppies and dogs super fat. But you know what I mean? You can also do this for yourself by providing like physical rewards, artificial rewards that you give yourself in lieu of the bigger reward. One way we see people do this is by creating a schedule for positive reinforcement. That's an incredible behavioral change strategy. So people do this for savings goals a lot. I see this a lot on like TikTok and Instagram and I love seeing these every like $100, $200, $1,000 they save. $20, $50, whatever it is goes into buying something that they really, really want so that there is that reinforcement that's going along with the hard work.
你给小狗的零食越多，它们就会变得越听话，据说是这样，但这总是适得其反，把我的小狗和狗子们喂得超级胖。但你知道我的意思吗？你也可以为自己这样做，比如提供物质奖励、人工奖励，用这些来代替更大的奖励。我们看到人们做到这一点的方法之一，就是为积极强化制定一个时间表。这是一个不可思议的行为改变策略。所以人们经常为储蓄目标这样做。我在TikTok和Instagram上经常看到这个，我喜欢看到他们每次存够100美元、200美元、1000美元时那种感觉。20美元、50美元，随便多少，都会用来买他们真正、真正想要的东西，这样就会有一种强化伴随着辛苦的工作。
We all kind of do want a special little thing every now and again. We want a break every now and again. We want a sweet treat every now and again. and factor that into how you are going about your goals, whatever it is, especially if it's a goal that is really based on a deficit of something. So having less saving money, having less sweet treats, having less downtime because you're working really, really hard, you can use that as a form of motivation to make you want to work harder so that you
我们其实都希望偶尔能有一点特殊的小东西。我们希望偶尔能休息一下。我们希望偶尔能吃点甜食。并把这一点考虑到你实现目标的进程中，无论是什么目标，特别是如果这是一个真正基于某种缺失的目标。比如减少存钱，减少吃甜食，因为你工作非常非常努力而减少休息时间，你可以把它当作一种动力形式，让你想要更努力地工作，这样你就能
finally get the reward. We see like studies on this with rats all the time. you know, the more that they are reinforced in a structured way. So, you know, they finish a task, they get a treat. They finish the next task. It's a little bit harder. They get a treat. The more that there is that structured reward, they end up performing better. They're more efficient. They tire less easily. And let's just say this, that it's not like a factor to do with energy. Like the reward is sometimes like they get to see their friend or the reward is like a pat. Like it's not always food base. but they actually keep going for longer.
最终得到奖励。我们经常看到关于老鼠的这方面的研究。你知道，它们受到的结构化强化越多。所以，你知道，它们完成了一个任务，就得到一个奖励。它们完成了下一个任务。稍微难一点。它们得到一个奖励。这种结构化的奖励越多，它们的表现最终就会越好。它们的效率更高。它们不那么容易感到疲倦。让我们这么说吧，这并不是一个与能量有关的因素。比如奖励有时是它们能见到朋友，或者奖励是一个轻拍。比如它不总是基于食物的，但它们实际上能坚持更长时间。
The reason this is the case in scientifically, neurologically, the reason this is the case all comes down to dopamine. I think we all know like dopamine is the happy chemical. Dopamine is also the motivational chemical. It is the chemical that gets you to do things. So if you want to increase the dopamine that you are accessing when doing hard things, you've got to provide some form of catalyst for the release of that, some form of trigger, some form of reward. It will make you happier, but it will also make you more motivated. There you go. The more you know.
在科学上、神经学上之所以会这样，原因全在于多巴胺。我想我们都知道，多巴胺是快乐化学物质。多巴胺也是动机化学物质。它是让你做事的化学物质。因此，如果你想在做难事时增加你所接触到的多巴胺，你必须为这种释放提供某种催化剂，某种触发器，某种奖励。这会让你更快乐，但也会让你更有动力。就是这样。你知道得越多。
So when we do this, it's actually what creates intrinsic motivation. This is the first form of motivation we're going to be talking about. Intrinsic motivation is when you do things just because you love them and just because you find them enjoyable. So you don't have to force yourself to do things you love, right? like I wouldn't have to force you to go to the beach or I wouldn't have to force you to like have a wine with your friends or force you to read your favorite book because you just like doing it. And one way that we can make it so that we enjoy doing something, which is the highest form of motivation for actually doing it, is by associating positive experiences and reward with performance, determination, commitment, with, you know, doing the thing with being persistent. Now, I know what you're probably thinking. How do I fall in love with doing something that is just actually so frustrating and annoying and something that I really don't want to do? And like, how do I enjoy my job that involves firing people? How do I fall in love with the process there? Or how do I
所以当我们这样做时，这实际上创造了内在动机。这是我们要谈论的第一种动机。内在动机是指你做事情纯粹是因为你热爱它们，纯粹是因为你觉得它们令人愉快。所以你不需要强迫自己去做你喜欢的事情，对吧？就像我不必强迫你去海滩，或者我不必强迫你和朋友喝一杯，或者强迫你读你最喜欢的书，因为你就是喜欢做这些事。我们可以让我们享受做某事的一种方法——这是实际去做它的最高形式的动机——就是将积极的体验和奖励与表现、决心、承诺联系起来，与（你知道的）坚持不懈地做事联系起来。现在，我知道你可能在想什么。我如何才能爱上一件其实如此令人沮丧、恼火且我真的不想做的事情？就像，我如何享受包含解雇员工的工作？我如何在其中爱上这个过程？或者我如何
fall in love with my painful IVF treatment? You know, that just sucks. Or like, how do I become intrinsically motivated to enjoy cleaning my toilet. There's just some things where this isn't possible, like we can't use this hedonic or pleasure principle. So the next best thing that you can aim for is integrated motivation. So this occurs when a behavior is performed to gain both an external reward, but it also aligns with your sense of identity, your sense of, your internal sense of value and interests and who you are as a person.
爱上我那痛苦的试管婴儿（IVF）治疗？你知道，那真的很糟糕。或者，如何才能对清洁马桶产生内在动机来享受它？有些事情就是不可能做到这一点的，比如我们不能使用这种享乐或快乐原则。所以你能争取到的次优选择是整合动机。当执行一项行为不仅是为了获得外部奖励，而且还符合你的认同感、你的内在价值感、兴趣以及你作为人的本质时，这种情况就会发生。
We can make our motivation to complete a task attached to our identity. And it's super, super powerful. You know, I clean the toilet because I am someone who is conscientious and I'm someone who cares about cleanliness and I care about having a nice environment. And because I am someone who cares about the details, even though I don't enjoy this, I'm going to do it because it reinforces something that I find important about my identity. I go through IVF treatment even when it's painful, even when it's hard, because I want to be a parent. That is something I have always felt is a deep part of my life purpose. So I will
我们可以将完成任务的动机与我们的身份联系起来。这是超级、超级强大的。你知道，我打扫马桶是因为我是一个有责任心的人，我是一个关心清洁度、关心拥有一个美好环境的人。正因为我是一个关注细节的人，尽管我不喜欢这样，但我还是会去做，因为它强化了我认为对我的身份很重要的东西。我经历试管婴儿治疗，即使它很痛苦，即使它很艰难，因为我想成为父母。这是我一直觉得是我人生目标深处的一部分。所以我将
endure the hard part of this journey because the outcome is something that is significant for my identity. The second best way that you can do hard things is to get super clear on the why and make a really, really big picture, like give it a meaning as big as life itself. Like I study because I believe in creating a better life for myself and I am someone who is a hard worker. So this behavior, although it is hard, is something that reinforces what I believe about myself. It reinforces my self-concept. It reinforces my confidence. This is who I am. So who would I be if I didn't do this behavior? Who would I be if I didn't do these hard things? This is just so, so powerful for taking something that is just, you know, a random thing on your to-do list, or maybe not,
忍受这段旅程艰难的部分，因为结果对我的身份具有重大意义。你能做难事的第二好方法是，把“为什么”搞得超级清楚，并描绘一幅真正、真正宏大的画面——赋予它一个大如生命本身的意义。比如我学习是因为我相信为自己创造更好的生活，我是一个努力工作的人。因此，这种行为虽然很困难，但它强化了我对自己的信念。它强化了我的自我概念。它强化了我的自信。这就是我是谁。所以如果我不这样做，我会是谁？如果我没有做这些难事，我会是谁？这对于把一件仅仅是（你知道的）你待办事项清单上的随机事情——或者也许不是——
taking something that you have, you know, mixed feelings towards, it's uncomfortable, it's difficult, and it becomes this thing, this gateway to being a more true, authentic version of yourself. and of course you are going to want to do that hard thing over the hard thing that is just bothersome over the hard thing that you have no meaning attached to. Finally, you know, if that doesn't work, if the intrinsic motivation doesn't work and the like integrated motivation systems don't work, you can always rely on extrinsic motivation. And that is basically doing things publicly, doing things in a public setting in front of others, promising others that you're going to do it as a way to make you feel like you're accountable,
把一件你（你知道的）怀有复杂感情的事情，它让人感到不舒服、困难，然后把它变成这样一件事情——通往更真实、更真实的自我版本的途径。你当然会愿意去做那件难事，而不是那件仅仅令人烦恼、没有任何意义依附其上的难事。最后，你知道，如果这不管用，如果内在动机不管用，整合动机系统不管用，你总是可以依靠外在动机。这基本上就是公开做事，在其他人面前的公共环境中做事，向别人承诺你要这样做，以此让你感到有责任感，
make you feel like there are eyes on you. This is all rooted in social psychology. When we think that people are watching, we tend to behave better. We tend to put on our best behavior. You can use those same principles to force yourself to do hard things. one of my friends does this in an excellent way. She studies in very public places because it, you know, makes her feel almost embarrassed to go on her phone, like the acknowledgement that someone could be watching her.
让你觉得有无数双眼睛在盯着你。这全都植根于社会心理学。当我们认为有人在看时，我们往往会表现得更好。我们往往会表现出最好的一面。你可以利用同样的原则来强迫自己做难事。我的一个朋友就用了一种极好的方式来做到这一点。她在非常公开的地方学习，因为这（你知道的）让她在玩手机时几乎感到尴尬，比如意识到可能会有人在看她。
And someone might be like, oh, God, she's going on her phone. Like, that's not good. I thought she was studying. Yes, sometimes it might not be the best for certain goals or certain behaviors. But in terms of things where you're like, I just need to get this done. And I need someone who, you know, a stranger doesn't even know me. I just need their presence to make me feel obligated to do this. Incredibly powerful.
而且可能有人会说，哦，天哪，她在玩手机。这可不好。我以为她在学习。是的，有时它可能不适合某些目标或某些行为。但在某些事情上，你会觉得，我只需要把这个搞定。我需要一个甚至不认识我的陌生人。我只需要他们的存在来让我感到有义务去完成这件事。超级强大。
That was my final tip for the day. We talked about intrinsic, integrated, an external or extrinsic motivation. Intrinsic is the best, actually finding a way to enjoy or fall in love with the process. Secondly, you can find a way to make the activity a part or a reinforcer of an important part of your identity. And then if all that fails, you know, the first. floodgates roll open, you can rely on the judgment of others. Less than ideal, but sometimes important. I really hope that this episode has given you some motivation. You know, we've got one month left of this year. We've got so much going on. We have a lot of goals that we might want to achieve. And we also
那是我的今天最后一条建议。我们讨论了内在、整合和外部或外在动机。内在动机是最好的，实际上是找到一种享受或爱上这个过程的方法。其次，你可以找到一种方法，使这项活动成为你身份中重要的一部分或强化剂。然后，如果这一切都失败了，你知道，第一道闸门敞开，你可以依靠他人的判断。虽然不够理想，但有时很重要。我真的希望这一集能给你带来一些动力。你知道，今年还剩下一个月。我们有太多事情要忙。我们有很多可能想要实现的目标，我们也
might be like preparing for next year. So I think these strategies are really, really doable and they're not about discipline. They're not about like working yourself to the bone. They're not a lot, not about burnout and exhaustion. They are small things that you can do mentally, psychologically, to be more productive and less busy and to reach your goals faster by essentially like tricking how our brain works and tricking our psychology. So if you did enjoy this episode, please make sure that you have left a five-star review. If you leave a review on Apple as well, I'm looking at all of them at the moment.
可能会在为明年做准备。所以我认为这些策略真的、真的很可行，而且它们与纪律无关。它们与拼命工作无关。它们与职业倦怠和精疲力竭无关。它们是你可以从精神上、心理上做的小事，让你更有效率，减少忙碌，并通过本质上欺骗我们大脑运作方式和心理学来更快地实现你的目标。因此，如果你确实喜欢这一集，请确保你已经留下了五星好评。如果你也在苹果上留下评论，我目前正在看所有的评论。
I'm like grabbing some out for a little post at the end of the year. I would really appreciate if you could leave some kind words there. Also make sure you have pre-ordered the book. I know I've been kind of not on the ball with reminding you guys. But yeah, it comes out next year and there will be a link in the podcast episode description. Even if you just want to check out the cover, that's totally fine. I just appreciate any support that you are giving me this like crazy amazing time in my life. Make sure you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast.
我正挑出一些用于年底的小帖子。如果你能在那里留下一些美言，我将不胜感激。另外，请确保你已经预订了这本书。我知道我一直在提醒大家方面做得不太到位。但是，是的，它将于明年发行，播客剧集的描述中会有一个链接。即使你只想看看封面，也完全没问题。在这个我生命中疯狂而美妙的时期，我感谢你们给予我的任何支持。请确保在Instagram上关注我们：That Psychology Podcast。
And until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会谈话。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起谈论这些。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以艰难的方式学习》。2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
这就是走楼梯的人的比例。当同时也有自动扶梯可用时。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands.
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时。她们采取了属于自己的行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast.
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。